es el punto 25 una solución de este
sistema y aquí tenemos dos desigualdades
y es mayor o igual que 2 x 1 y x es más
grande que uno y aquí queremos ver si el
punto 25 es solución de este sistema es
decir lo que tenemos que hacer es
sustituir el valor de x por 2 y el valor
de g por 5 en ambas desigualdades para
ver si realmente llegamos a dos
desigualdades verdaderas así que de la
primera lo que voy a hacer es sustituir
a x por 2 y allí por 5 entonces me queda
que 5 es mayor o igual que dos por dos
más uno lo que hice fue meter un 2 aquí
en el valor de x y un 5 en valor de 10 y
entonces me queda que 5 es mayor o igual
que 2 por dos más uno lo cual es 5 y
esto es cierto sigue es cierto porque 5
cigüela 5 y por lo tanto 5 es mayor o
igual a 5 por lo tanto esto si lo cumple
porque es igual y bueno vamos a ver si
cumple también la segunda desigualdad y
la segunda disuelta me dice que x es más
grande que 1 por lo tanto x en este
punto vale 2 y 2 es más grande que 1
es cierto y entonces puedo concluir que
este punto 25 cumplen ambas
desigualdades lo que quiere decir que
este punto es parte de la solución de
este sistema